both parties are invested very heavily
in this race but the GOP is taking an
all-hands-on-deck approach and an
attempt to hold this coveted seat and
with just a few hours left to go the
Trump family is sending in one of its
own
Republicans are pouring out the sugar in
Pennsylvania from Donald Trump jr.
making a stop at Sara's candies and
Canonsburg today I'm excited to have
someone in they're actually helping
fight my with my father for these things
against some of these obstructionists on
the other side to the presidential
family patriarch filling an airport
hangar outside pittsburgh over the
weekend we need our congressmen ciccone
we have to have him state Rep rick
ciccone has the full throated backing of
party and president president trumps in
your corner how can you lose in a
district the president won by nearly 20
points
ciccone should have the edge but
Democrat Connor Lam has sought to avoid
alienating Trump's faithful he is
pro-gun and here in Steele country he's
expressed support for the president's
new tariffs former VP Joe Biden stumped
for the Marine Corps veteran last week
lamb has earned union support from
carpenters to coal miners and at a rally
on Sunday he vowed to push back against
Republicans on Social Security and
Medicare I do not believe as Paul Ryan
does that these are entitlements for
another form of welfare as you exit and
while he's worked to distance himself
from Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi the
president has dubbed him lamda sham
lamda sham
he's trying to act like a Republican so
he gets he won't give me one vote
locally the race is impossible to ignore
with ads blanketing the airwaves
ciccone knows how to keep us safe Connor
land is running for Congress at Bob
Steiner in Carnegie waitress Jodi Kelly
says she's voting corner lam J's about
education just health care which when
you're in this profession need a better
health care that what we have now but a
third generation coal miner tells us
he's behind Ciccone because we need more
conservatives in Washington to support
Trump and help him get his agenda
nationally this race is being watched
very closely with an eye towards the
midterms the looming question of course
is a potential Ciccone loss and what
that could potentially mean for the
president's Prower prowess going forward
the voters hit the polls tomorrow
John something the president doesn't
even want to think about thanks very
much small in line for us tonight in
Carnegie Pennsylvania